Okay. Hi everyone. It's uh Orderflows
trade recap for September 1st, 2016. My
name is Michael Valtos. I'm the founder
and trader at
orderflows.com. First, a brief
disclaimer. This presentation is for
educational andformational purposes only
and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. Past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. Okay. The tools that are used
in this presentation is uh mainly the
order flows trader uh software which is
my main volume footprint chart and it
runs on the Ninja Trader trading
platform. You can download Ninja Trader
Trading platform for free at
www.ninjettrader.com. Okay, so you know,
I had one trade that I was able to get
off during the room this morning and
yeah, it ended up being a scratch. It
was in the money pretty quick and then
it uh sort of started going up against
me. I just got out for a scratch and was
looking for another opportunity later.
It did appear and I was just too slow
and I didn't get filled and I missed the
missed it. But, you know, sort of coming
into today, let me just, you know, sort
of step it back a little bit. Uh, you
know, it's hard to see it now, but, uh,
you know, early in the
session, you got to use your imagination
a little bit here. The volume
profile, you had a value area here. Um,
you know, you had the high at 4 in the
morning and, you know, on on a normal
chart, you know, at the time, you know,
this was coming out to here. It's just
because we put a lot of volume in later
in the day. looks smaller now, but you
know coming into the US session you had
an earlier value area high here and then
you know around seven you started
getting a lower value area lower point
of control you know initial your first
point of control was was up in here
around the 76 and then later after you
know coming into the US session you know
7 8:00 you had a new lower point of
control so you had initially you had
this one up here and then you put in a
lower one and then you know after cash
open you put in a lower one. So, you had
three lower points of controls uh
forming early in the day. Um, you know,
right now it's hard to see that because,
you know, this is the full day chart and
we put in a shitload more volume uh
later in the day that uh you know, makes
those those numbers look small. But, uh
so anyway, you know, I had that in my
mind that hey, you know, we're putting
in these lower points of controls on the
volume profile and when you're doing
that, you're going to have a a higher
chance
of going lower. Now the other thing was
let me pull up a 10 the 10 range chart
which is also important. Okay, this is
the 10 range chart. Now this is August
31st the day before and I drew these
lines in there. You can do that on Ninja
Trader F6 and you'll draw a horizontal
line and what it is I drew this first
line here at uh I don't know what that
is 69 and a quarter. This was
yesterday's point of control. This other
line up here is yesterday's value area
high and I used this line at 62 and 3/4
as the value area low.
Okay, so value area high, value area
low, yesterday's point of control. Now,
we were coming into the
session at, you know, 8, you know, 8 in
the morning and we're just trading
around, we're, you know, trading inside
yesterday's value area and we're hanging
around yesterday's point of control.
Now, we started coming, you know, what
I'm looking for is if we get below
yesterday's point of control, I'm
looking for a move down to the value
area low. And if we get below that value
area low, then you know it's I think
it's going to be lights out. We're going
to go lower. And so what happened
was we started trading below and this is
a 10 range chart. We started trading
below the value area low. Sorry, the the
point of control. And go back to the
three range chart real quick.
Um what time was that? Just before
9. And I got short here, you know, we
started making new lows, you know, and
you know, I I was seeing we're getting
sort of these waves of selling coming
in, you know, 850, uh, you know, decent
negative delta, you know, 851 again, a
negative delta every minute. You know,
852, strong one, and, you know, even
853. So, I got short at 7. You know, I
thought, hey, this is the move. We're
going to make the run for the value area
low and hopefully take it out. And, you
know, I got short at 7 and a half. I
threw it. I had a bid in at five. And
what do you do? So, as luck would have
it, is there luck in trading? I I don't
like to rely on luck, but you know, to
me, this is how I would describe luck in
trading when you got a bid in at five.
And as low as it gets is is five and a
quarter, one tick from your your
takerit. You know, what can you do? You
can't stare at the screen and make it go
there. You know, lots of times, you
know, people are like, "Come on,
cheering for it." And the market can't
hear you cheering and, you know, the
market's not gonna uh react that way.
And we started coming up. Um, you know,
even, you know, I really liked it
because, you know, I had three in a row.
Had the delta surge kicking off. You
know, I got this very strong negative
delta. And then what happens? Just hits
here. Very small volume though. Though
this is the price rejector given a buy
and it did turn around. I ended up
covering it at, you know, at a scratch.
I scratched it at 7 and a half. Um,
yeah. I don't know. Uh, people say, "Oh,
you chickened out. You weren't willing
to take heat." But, you know, really I I
don't like to get short and have the
market make a move, go back up to my
entry price and then expect it to make
the move again. Usually, you know, you
get short, it makes a move, okay,
doesn't quite get there and reverses. It
just keeps going up and up and up. It
just happened, you know, so be it that
it it it turned around, you know, I'm
looking at some very nice buying
imbalances here. 8 or um, you know, 986,
500, 2,000. You know, am I going to
fight that or, you know, hey, I could
cover it here at at nothing. you know, I
don't want to be covering it up here at
at 8 and a half and losing a point on
it. You know, I'm fine to take the
scratch, you know, and and look for the
next trade. But, you know what, and you
know, we had a number coming out at nine
as well. So, do I want to sit through
the number? In this case, you know, the
number helped the market sell off. Uh,
but again, I'm not going to hold this
this position through a number. I mean,
that that's ridiculous. only people that
are looking to trade around numbers are
are the um I'll say the uninformed but
you know said look I'm not an economist
I read the order flow I want to react to
it and you know when a number comes out
everything changes so you know having a
view based on the order flow before a
number and then number comes out and
everything is going to change you know I
don't want to still be in that position
after the number comes out I'd rather
wait for the number to come out uh the
market to settle down and you know
everyone to take their views again on on
in the market and you can see is jumping
around pretty quick. You know, 9:00,
9:00, 9:00, you know, this is all within
that 1 second. It's moving pretty fast.
So, you know, I scratched it, you know,
but yeah, people say, "Oh, yeah, if you
stayed in it, yeah, you could have had
winner." Yeah, but I'm not going to sit
through a number. Um, you know, people
that will try and talk you to sit
through a number, you know, good on good
on them. Um, you know, let them uh, you
know, trade their way. I I'll trade my
way. And, you know, so that was, you
know, that was the one trade. you know,
the market did settle down a bit later.
I did try to get uh get short again here
on on this move here. This is 9 uh just
after 910. You had uh ratio ratio ratio
starting to come down and I tried to get
short at this point of control 7 and a
half and I missed it. I I I couldn't,
you know, by the time I was, you know, I
was talking about something else and by
the time I tried you got my order in, I
missed it.
And you know, okay, I missed it and
that's fine. I mean, part of the reason
I have the trading room is just so I
could talk to other traders and get
them, you know, teach them a bit on
order flow, you know, talk about what
I'm seeing in the market, not just for
me to trade. Um, there's a lot of other
times in the day to
trade. And so, you know, I missed it.
Okay. I left my offer in. I saw this,
you know, you know, so imagine if I'm
short here at seven, sorry, this was uh
seven and three/4ers, not seven and a
half.
And there's a nice stack sell imbalance
right there. Okay. And thinking uh you
know now this we're going to go down
into lows making lows. Oh trading gods
you know today's not my day. You know I
got I scratched the trade earlier and I
missed this trade here. This looks nice.
But then what happens? We have this
stack selling imbalance which to me is
you know a bearish sign. And what do we
do? We just go sideways one two three
four bars already. you know, when we're
in this third bar, I already I canceled
my offer. Um, I don't want to still, you
know, I don't want to still be trying to
get short here at 7 and a half when I
have this very bearish signal here and
the market's not going lower. You know,
what's going to happen? I I think, you
know, and is, you know, if we get, you
know, the further we get into this
imbalance zone that, you know, if we
can't pull away, chances are we're going
to go the other way. Uh but once we get
past, you know, this is one, two, three,
four bars. Once you get past the fifth
bar, you know, this one really it's all
bets are off. I mean, this thing, you
know, the further out you get, further
away from it you get, the
less importance it carries, I think. And
you know, so I canceled my my offer and
what happens when you trade up to 8 and
a half. Okay. You know, yeah, I kept my
offer in at, you know, 7 and 3/4. Yeah,
I would have been filled and, you know,
taken, you know, what is that? Three
ticks of heat. Um, you know, and it did
go off and and continue to make new
lows. But, I mean, you got to be
realistic in in your
trading. I'm getting, you know, I wanted
to get short off of this. Okay. And then
I get another bearish signal. I miss it.
Okay. So, I got an offer in there. And
then the market gives you another
bearish signal, but doesn't go any
lower. You know, do you still want to be
short? No, I don't want to be. Um, and
you know, so I I canceled it. Okay.
Because reason, you know, I don't want
to be short way over here based on, you
know, my analysis from, you know, 5
minutes ago. I'd rather be short and
catch a quick move rather than, you
know, wait for the market to come back,
fill me, and hopefully it'll make that
move. you know, in in today, you know,
today's examples where um yeah, if if
you waited, you know, in this case, you
know, the market did come back, it made
a little bit of a move, came back, and
then made another move. Often times it
doesn't do that, you know. So, it's
it's, you know, am I willing to risk the
times it does
it for the times it doesn't or wish the
times it doesn't do it for the times
that it does it? Um, you know, I just
rather I'd rather not take those trades.
Um, you know, I'd rather not take those
chances. It does it, sometimes it
doesn't. Sometimes, you know, sometimes
it'll work, sometimes it wouldn't. You
know, that's not a very scientific
thing. But, um, I mean, these were the
the two trades that, you know, one I was
able to get in, the other one I missed,
and I just, you know, I just hung it up.
Now, getting back to the 10 range chart.
Okay.
Now again, you know, I have this line
here. This is the lower end of the value
area, the value area low. And you know,
it was at two and a quarter. And I I I
really was waiting for it again. I was,
you know, it's in the room. I was
talking to somebody about something
else. And we hit it and wow, we just,
you know, fell over really quick. I I
didn't have a chance to sell it. I was
looking at the bonds at that time, but,
you know, it was a very nice quick move.
um you know at 9:30 literally within a
few minutes we're trading um you know
about four points
lower and you know why is that
important? Well when you trade out uh
you know it was early in the day it's
only 9:30 you really haven't formed your
value area yet for today. I mean, yeah,
you got some decent volume. Thing you
got to remember, right? S&Ps trade about
30% of the volume up until uh cash
open. So, you know, the value area that
you have from
overnight is going to change really
quick because you traded, you know, less
than a third of your day's volume over
the last, I don't know what that is, 20
hours. No, I say 20 hours, 16 hours.
So you know it's going to change once
cash opens and you get you get you know
three four times as much volume going
through. So like I said you know earlier
you have these you know value areas
which look much bigger but you know
during the course of the day you're
going to put in more volume and it's
going to really expand. you know,
earlier coming in at at uh, you know,
7:00, you're looking at 10 thou, you
know, 8,000, 9,000, you know, 10,000 and
and on the volume profile at, you know,
when those are the big numbers, they
really stick out like this. Now, you
know, at the end of the day, you had 50,
60, 70,000. It sticks out much more than
than these. But what's important is, you
know, that value area that you have
earlier, is it important? Yes, it is.
But really, yesterday's value area is
also important. So, we were trading
inside yesterday's value area most of
the morning, early part of the morning.
So, if you get outside that value area,
you know what's going to happen? One,
you can trade back into it. Or two, you
can move away from it. And it's when you
start to move away from it, you can get
the big moves. You know, are um you
know, additional traders going to be
coming. I mean, when I say additional
traders, I mean more long-term money
traders, you know, people that are
taking positions and holding them for
for weeks as opposed to day traders or
swing
traders, you know, new money, so to
speak, new positions coming in. And, you
know, how do you how do you sort of see
that? Well, you see that in the
imbalances here. Um, you know, that's,
you know, to me, this is not day traders
getting getting short. Um, you know, day
traders, you know, when when they see
the value area low, they start they want
to buy it. and think we're going to
trade back up into the value area, lower
value area for the day. But, you know,
once you start moving away from the
value, we okay, the market is done with
that value area. Now, it's going to look
for another value area. That's what the
markets do. They move, they always
searching for value. You know, they're
always looking for the next value area.
So, now, you know, this area between 63
and, you know, 70 is yesterday's value
area. Now, it's going to be looking for,
you know, the next value area. And, you
know, it it it came in and, you know,
around between 9:50 and 10:30 or 11:00,
we spent a lot of time down here. You
know, these bars got a lot of volume.
You got one bar here,
130,000, almost 140. You got a bar here
almost 100,000. It's at 94,000. This one
here is 50,000.
So, you know, it found a new value area
for the time being down here, you know,
and people were happy to trade. You
know, you got a bar with 50,000
contracts traded. It's only got a delta
of 700. You know, people are happy to to
trade here. There's only a difference
between buyers and sellers of, you know,
700 is not much. Um, you know, and
that's right off the low. So, you know,
it found this new level down in here for
the time being. Okay. it didn't want to
continue any lower and it traded back up
into yesterday's value area and that's
where it uh you know that that's where
it spent the rest of the day. So you
know I said it tried to find this new
value area. It sort of found it but you
know maybe price was uh too cheap down
here
that you know it traded back up in there
but you know markets always are
searching for value area. So, if you're
going to get that move outside the value
area, you know, it's important, you
know, yesterday's value area.
So, anyway guys, um you know, I'll end
it today. I said, you know, there was
two uh there's three trades. Again, I
missed the one out when we started
breaking out the value area because I
was chatting about the bonds at the
time, but you know what it I I I wanted
to include it on this video so you can
see it and understand uh the importance
of it. So, you know, thanks for watching
this video. To learn more about uh
trading with the order flow, the
software that I created to help me
analyze the order flow,
uh visit my website,
www.orderflows.com. So, thanks everyone
and see you on the inside. Bye-bye.